I've put these names on the board
because today we're talking about the
so-called Carolingian renaissance,
the revival of learning under
Charlemagne and his successors,
but the figures of this renaissance,
the intellectuals of Charlemagne,
his court of the court of Louis,
the pious,
the court of Charles the
bald are not household names.
And I just want to give you a sample.
And it is no more than
a sample of these men.
And I'm afraid they all were
men. Uh, and most of them, um,
monks, uh, uh, or other kinds of clerics.
And what I want to do today is
reminds you for the first to start,
we said last time that Charlemagne's
rule was based on a combination of
traditional war leadership similar
to that of the mirror of engines,
an alliance with the church similar
to the Merovingians, but much closer,
much closer in the sense of seeing the,
um,
legitimation of rule up to
the point of emperor as a,
a product of what later would be
called sacred monarchy. In other words,
that the kingship was not just rulership
over the populous or over warriors.
It was that.
But it was also a
responsibility and ministry,
the word that's used,
uh,
to see to the salvation of the public
good and not just the secular benefit of
the public good as in a modern state,
but to the salvation of the people
that God would hold the emperor,
the king responsible for this. And
then the third element was, uh,
to revive the Roman Empire.
And not just as a political entity,
but the Roman empire as a state,
as a form of rulership for the
benefit of a diverse population,
not just one nation like the Franks
or the lombards or the Saxons,
but of a kind of imperial confederation.
Uh,
the Carolingian renaissance
is a planned one,
unlike the regular old
Italian renaissance,
which is a spontaneous revival of learning
in several different cities on the
parts of intellectuals.
The Italian renaissance,
like most revivals of learning might've
been patronized by secular rulers,
but it's impetus was not
the state in this case.
However,
we have a program of reviving Latin,
reviving the classical
literature and texts,
teaching
these subjects and all of this not
in aid of what we would call a purely
educational program,
but to help the state
and to help its mission,
which as we've just said is both
a Christian and a Roman one.
The revival of letters was intended then
to restore and deepen the piety of the
population,
the understanding of Christianity,
the restoration of the church
as an intellectual force,
the preservation of learning from both
Roman secular and religious texts.
So that Charlemagne's cultural program
is the culmination of a longer period of
trying to save something from the
wreckage of classical civilization.
And thus as a Christian
ruler and as a Roman emperor,
Charlemagne surrounded himself
with these and other intellectuals,
monks and scholars,
in order to understand this mission.
However, beyond just saying, oh,
Christianity or classical culture,
we have to go back to some topics we
touched on very lightly when we were
talking about monasticism and
that have cropped up now and then.
So I want to start out
with the preservation of
learning up to the point that
Charlemagne really starts putting
together this program, uh,
around seven 80 a day
you'll remember.
And you love a scene from Augustine's
confessions among other things that the
ideal of Roman culture at the time of the
empire was a cultivated leisure on the
part of wealthy,
well educated lay people.
That is to say even after
Constantine's conversion,
the intellectuals of the
empire tended to be not clergy,
but wealthy people who
could afford the leisure,
the time,
and the expense of procuring
books and of discussing them.
These were the people who represented
the continuation of the literary and
philosophical traditions of
classical Greece and Rome.
And this also had a practical benefit
just as a rather than a different way it
does now in order to enter
Roman governmental service,
which was the most successful career path
of the time of Saint Augustine and had
been for some centuries,
you needed to have an education of
a certain rather rarefied hire sort.
And this is not unique to
the Roman empire. It was
true of imperial China. Most,
obviously in China,
you had to pass a very tough exam,
a very selective examine,
order to be a part of the highest
level of the imperial service.
And the exam was not a political
science exam or you know,
a business decisions kind of exam.
It wasn't a, you know, like, uh,
you have, um, uh,
a certain kind of budget and you've
got to allocate resources or, you know,
it's not a, it's not a problem
set. Uh, it was poetry, uh,
was, uh, uh, a ancient culture.
And the same thing is true of the British
empire in the 19th century. You know,
in order to enter its
highest, uh, levels, uh,
you needed to know Greek and Roman, not
because in fact you were Greek and Latin,
not because you were
going to use them, uh, uh,
governing some colony, uh, in
Southeast Asia for example.
But because that was what
made you an educated person.
So,
um,
the centers of learning in the
ancient world included Athens,
the platonic and Athenian Academies,
uh,
Pergamum in Asia Minor, uh, who's, uh,
the name of which city gave its
name to parchment, uh, Alexandria,
which had an entity called the museum,
which was not what we now call a museum,
but rather a kind of library
and research center. Uh,
Constantinople later
Alexandria is the most famous because it
had this magnificent library as part of
the museum and the mystery of
what happened to this library, um,
allegedly burned by the
Muslims in the seventh,
eighth century on the
grounds that, uh, uh,
you didn't need to know anything
except what's in the Koran. And, um,
this is not true now.
The library had disappeared long before
the eighth century and probably was the
victim of the kinds of disorders that
began in the third century when we began
the course.
That kind of disruptions of local
society opportunities for plunder,
neglect, and, um, uh,
the museum was actually closed
by the Emperor Caracalla, uh,
in the third century.
So the major problem of the
Roman Empire in terms of the, uh,
diminution of learning is not a,
the burning of Alexandria
or such dramatic events.
It's a much more gradual process.
And this gradual process involves what
we have at various times using Wickham's
language called the radical
simplification of material culture,
which means not only a
lack of imported goods,
more primitive accommodations,
uh, fewer kinds of, um,
uh,
less trade and commerce,
but also much less than the
way of books and learning.
This is also related to the
disappearance of lay literacy.
The people who were capable of reading
and writing in Latin as of let's say the
sixth century,
are overwhelmingly clerics and not all
that many of them either the last grand
figures of Roman classical culture,
our,
but we theists and Casio Doris,
and we've mentioned them
already, but a big bear,
but we feel this
for 80 to five, 24. And Casio Doris
four 92,
five 85,
Casio Doris was a monk and it is his
accomplishment to join monasticism to the
preservation of learning. And he had
a very long life to do it as well.
Reminding us that not everybody just
kicked off at the age of 35 in the
preindustrial world of,
but we theist didn't have a particularly
long life because he was executed by
the Ostrogoths at King Theodoric
suspected of treason and plotting with
Byzantium.
Okay.
But we,
this could still work in his personal
library in Rome where the light filtered
in through alabaster windows,
the Beinecke library idea
onto cupboard stacked with Greek
and Roman [inaudible] books.
But, but we theists was among the last
secular intellectuals in the West and
particularly one of the last
to know Greek as well as Latin.
He conceived a project of translating
the great works of Greek philosophy into
Latin,
which would have include included
all of Plato and Aristotle,
but he was cut off by his arrest,
torture and execution after just having
done some introductory textbooks and
just a smattering of Plato and Aristotle
after him and the just any
antic invasion of Italy,
Italy was devastated. And even though
we're main of repository of manuscripts,
it's learning was preserved as a guttering
flame by monks like Casio Doris and
almost accidentally by the monks who
followed the rule of Saint Benedict.
St Benedict does, as you'll
recall, require reading,
but it's usually during lent
and it's a kind of penance.
The contribution of Casio Doris is the
organization of a more library like kind
of monastery and the notion that classical
culture is not just a collection of
texts about a discredited religion,
but necessary for Christian interpretation
of the Bible and Christian learning.
At his monastery of
vivarium in southern Italy,
Casio,
Doris developed a notion
of the liberal arts as an
aid to religious truth.
The liberal arts is not his invention,
but the notion of the
liberal arts culminating in
a program that has a purpose
in which classical culture is fused
with Christian culture is his doing.
He was not so much interested
in the aesthetic pleasure
of these classical texts
as in their use for
interpreting the Bible.
The Bible according to his Augustine's
and virtually everybody's understanding
of the time is not a text that makes
perfect sense in every respect.
Literally,
it is the book of life
that God has set up for us,
but it requires interpretation.
Okay?
It is not just a literal text.
It is a figurative and
prophetic one as well.
And in order to get at
what it really means,
what its real messages are,
you have to know things like mathematics,
astronomy, geometry, even music. Uh,
these, uh, and certainly
grammar, rhetoric and logic.
These are the seven liberal
arts of Casio Doris Curriculum,
right?
They're arranged in the three basic,
the trivium as it came to be called
the three, not because of trivial,
although that's where the word comes
from. The trivium I. U m T, R, I v, a,
u m logic, grammar, rhetoric.
Now I'm in this sort of, um,
Rick Perry moment, the quadrivium.
There are four of them. Okay?
Arithmetic, astronomy, geometry and
music. Okay? So I got all of them.
The quadrivium are the sciences.
You don't think music is a science,
uh, in the, uh, late Roman
medieval imagination.
It was the science of intervals
and of pleasing forms and of modes.
Okay.
The replication of this plan of Casio
Doris is the accomplishment of this period
in which classical learning
and it's texts were endangered.
The Benedictine monks of Italy.
Question and something I missed
the, for the quadrivium Quad, Q. U. A. D.
R. I. V. I. E. U. M. Sorry,
what were they? Oh God.
And you're putting me on the spot again.
It's y'all do y'all geometry,
geometry,
music, um, arithmetic and astronomy,
right?
This is the period in which the Irish
are critical to the preservation of
learning.
There was a book that was popular a few
years ago called how the Irish saved
civilization. Um, like many popular books,
this is a little bit reducing
things to a kind of easy formula,
but it is a Irish as well as Italian and
very much English monasticism under the
influence of both Italy and Ireland
that has a program of establishing
monasteries,
correcting and preserving Latin,
which has become increasingly distant
from what people actually speak.
And of course in Ireland,
not part of the Roman empire,
they had no tradition of
speaking Latin amongst,
had to learn Latin as an artificial or
a completely foreign language and in a
way that made their Latin better
because they didn't think that they,
uh,
kind of on the way to French or on the
way to spend it's language that was being
spoken in general, uh,
could be confused with Latin
in the critical period.
Five 50 and of the gothic wars in Italy,
devastation of Italy to seven 50
beginning of the Carolingian ascent.
Okay.
There are only 264 books that survive.
It is 264 manuscripts
and all but 26 of them deal
with religious subjects
of this,
26 of them,
eight deal with law eight with medicine,
six with grammar.
Now one reason that very little survives
is that these were mostly written on
Papaya Iris Scrolls,
which is not very durable.
Though there is a change underway
from about 402 writing on parchment,
which is very durable.
And accordingly,
along with this change to parchment is
a change from the scroll to the Codex.
So the triumph of the Codex
is roughly 400 a d two,
2010. Right? We're going
back to the scroll.
Actually we even use the word for the
process of going through a document on um,
uh, a, a, um, a computer or a kindle.
MMM.
How big are these libraries? How, how
many, how many texts do they have?
The largest library before Charlemagne
scent would have been the two libraries
associated with bead in
the north of England. Um,
and um,
perhaps a hundred bucks,
620.
But it's at this
setting,
the England of bead,
the early eighth century that we start
to have the monasteries that really
conform to our image of monks
diligently copying manuscripts,
the invention of what's called the
monastic scriptorium of place for writing.
So there are monks who not
only read but copy other books,
maybe borrowed from other
monasteries for too.
This is a laborious process and one that
we can follow because we tend to know
where our texts of classical learning
come from and by how slender a thread they
arrive. Um, uh, for us,
the monks would copy these documents,
they would be preserved in the library,
but again,
these monasteries close are plundered.
The,
uh,
wanderings of these manuscripts
then increase the fragility of,
uh,
what exists and what
we know yeah.
Mainly from libraries and extra.
Yeah.
The question is how do these monks in far
off north eastern England get ahold of
the classical texts they're brought
up with the missionaries there,
evidence of constant
communication with, uh, Italy,
which is probably the
source of most of them.
And they learned very quickly.
Remember I said that there's this, uh,
a magnificent codex of the Bible that's
now in Florence that was a gift of the
English to the pope in the
eighth century. So, um,
uh, there is traffic in these
extremely precious objects,
but it's very small scale and
very fragile as I've said,
until Charlemagne does,
is not so much innovate or
invent a program as make it
into something that's not
just an artisinal enterprise dependent
on a few monks in a few monasteries.
And it's part of what we've said is a
campaign to salvage a classical learning.
This, uh, um,
is encapsulated in one of Charlemagne's
governing instructions to his
administrative cadres.
He says,
we are concerned to
restore with diligence,
zeal the workshops of knowledge,
which through the negligence of
our ancestors have been well nigh,
deserted.
We invite others by our own example as
much as lies within our power to learn to
practice the liberal arts
as Wickham points out.
This is an unusual period of intellectuals
participating in and even to some
extent directing government.
It's always necessary for governments
to have some, uh, you know,
economists or a foreign
policy specialists,
but intellectuals in the sense of
promoting a program of liberal arts is
unusual. Or intellectuals
who are not just, you know,
decorators or an a
mentors of people who do.
Nice illuminated manuscripts
or beautiful, uh, you know,
fountains out of silver
with chirping birds. Um, uh,
the court of Charlemagne is a moment
of intense intellectual effort and
Charlemagne and his successors were
rulers who gave tremendous power,
privileges, even wealth, um,
to people who knew something
about classical learning.
The purpose of this is to standardize
education in the church and to make sure
that the church ran in a,
uh,
an effective manner and also to make
sure that the government ran in an
effective manner.
By effective,
I mean uniformity and discipline so
that you could go into a church in
Barcelona,
the south western corner of
Charlemagne's realm or um,
uh, in, uh, ochin at the, um,
court of Charlemagne or in Rome itself
and hear the same kind of liturgy or
ceremony or ritual that from one
corner of the Empire to the other,
the church laws would be the same,
that the discipline mete it out to a
misbehaving priests would be the same.
That preaching and missionary work
would be coordinated and uniform.
Even that spelling and the shape of
the letters might be standardized.
It is to Charlemagne and these
intellectuals that we owe.
The very beautiful way that we write,
as you can see,
my miniscule a print is um,
uh, you know, the product
of a monastic education. Uh,
these little letters write these
minuscule letters are Carolingian.
This is how, uh, uh, they
write in the Roman era,
they tend to write in a different fashion.
Um,
and in the, uh, mirror of engine
court visit golf courts, uh,
in a still different and quite difficult
to read, at least for us now fashion.
Uh, the spelling of Latin
is regularized at this time.
Okay.
The notion is that the
people would receive,
okay,
basic education and of course there's
some debate as to how wide a spectrum of
the populace this involves how much
education ordinary people were to receive,
but from the point of view of the
intellectuals fashioning this,
what was really important was
that the clergy receive a, um,
a good Latin education.
The problem of clerical literacy is a
persistent problem of the Middle Ages.
Clergy who may know
some formula to recite,
who don't actually know how to read or
who don't actually know what the Latin
words mean.
So this is a program
not just to save texts,
but to, um, uh,
to,
uh,
use them to apply them and also to
apply them to a level below that of
intellectuals sitting around
and discussing the ancient world
at the highest level.
Monastic centers collected and
copied Latin classical manuscripts
collected, commented,
collated. This is not a,
an intellectual program that
aims at entrepreneurship
or intellectual reality in
the sense of, um, innovation.
Wickham talks about Ama of mets.
Uh,
one of the people I didn't
put on here mlrs remember,
is condemned for, uh, um,
certain liturgical innovations and
he's astounded at being accused of
innovating. Uh, uh, he acknowledges
that this is not his job,
although he makes it worse
by saying that, um, uh,
he had found truth within
his own spirit saying,
I have found truth within
my own spirit. In, uh,
eight 48 d is not a proper answer because
that makes it sound as if your spirit
determines what truth is,
where its truth is determined by a much
longer biblical classical tradition and
that's what orthodoxy is.
So he sort of had to accept
his not incredibly severe
punishment but punishment
nonetheless.
Okay.
The Carolingian renaissance was organized
by a group of people who are from all
over. The place they had off from
Orlando is probably a visit golf.
Paul the Deacon is probably a
yard. Uh, Einhard is a frank,
the greatest of these figures.
Al Cohen,
who was more specifically
commissioned by Charlemagne too. Um,
and,
and alkynes dates are seven 30 to eight
oh four alk winners from North Umbria.
Now Quinn is from the
school established by bead.
These scholars, as you can see how
different areas of specialization
there enterprises or their duties
were to regularize liturgy,
to revive rhetoric,
moral theology,
logical argumentation,
poetry,
and to argue against
theological unorthodoxy.
The two theological problems of the
Carolingian empire were iconoclasm debates
about that,
which we've already seen in the byzantine
empire and inherit to see called
adoptionism.
Adoptionism
is the notion that Christ was a human
who was essentially adopted by God to
become his son.
It's a heresy that at the time of
Charlemagne was strong in Spain,
or at least defined as a
heresy, uh, and, uh, wiped out.
We said, uh, uh,
that they're 26 nonreligious manuscripts
from between five 50 and seven 54.
The ninth century.
There are 290 classical manuscripts,
154 the 10th.
So you can see the benign century
is kind of a golden age of this,
although again, we're not talking
about an incredible number of things,
not an incredible number, but
they're very, very important. Uh,
many of you have taken directed studies
the first year freshmen liberal arts,
great books program.
Well,
of course a ds doesn't like the
Middle Ages for a number of reasons.
So it's not as if ds decided that Lupus,
a fairy air is up there with
Plato and, um, through acidities.
But the things that you do read
in ds include, Olivia says,
a history of the Roman Empire,
Libby's history of the Roman empire,
tacit of the Roman republic.
Tacitus Bolivia's Libyan Tacitus are
authors who depend basically on one
manuscript and that manuscript is a
Carolingian manuscripts for Livy for
example,
there's a lot of his incredibly long
history that we don't have the so called
lost decades of Livy.
His work is divided into
a book's called decades.
The fact that we have as much of Livy as
we do is due to the Carolingian copying
programs.
The fact that we have Tacitus at all
is due basically to one manuscript.
CICERO's republic rediscovered in the
19th century is a palimpsest and you'll
have a herd in section. Um, and in,
uh,
the Beinecke he tour Palimpsest
is a manuscript that has
been scraped of its old
text,
a new text put on,
but the old text is usually
more interesting to us
than the new one and, uh,
uh,
can be restored and read.
Most of these are regarded as
discoveries of the renaissance.
But where the renaissance scholars found
them was in northern monasteries where
they had been copied and kept,
uh,
since Carolingian Times where then did
the Carolingian get their manuscripts,
where'd they get the things to copy?
Which, uh, is really a version of the,
a very perceptive question.
Um, uh, that was asked before.
Um, Italy for the most
part, especially Ravenna,
Monte Cassino and Rome itself.
So for example,
the German monastery of Laura Bush,
uh,
obtained from Italy,
an ancient manuscript
of Virgil and copied it.
They also have or copied Libby's fifth
decade that is part of living Roman
history.
The unique manuscript of the fifth
decade found in the renaissance at Loris,
copied it [inaudible] in the ninth century
from some papyruses Italian original
long since lost.
Okay.
In addition to Laura Bush, the centers
of learning include Aachen itself,
the court of Charlemagne,
Corby, Corb, I e
tour, t. O. U. R. S.
Okay.
Sang Gol, st s t and gall, g a, l. L.
And these libraries,
we can see their growth
during this period. So,
for example, uh, the monastery
of right now on an island
in lake cone stones
in 800 the year that Charlemagne
was crowned as Emperor
Ryka now had 50 bucks in
eight 46 it had a thousand.
Well,
all of this emphasis on education and
classical learning is extremely important
and indeed it merits those
kinds of, um, you know,
how blank saved blank how the Carolingian
saved classical civilization in this
case.
But it does not mark a break with the
piety and spirituality of the era.
And that's part of the point
of the Einhard reading.
Einhard is a critical figure in the court
of Charlemagne and of his son Louis,
the pious about whom you'll be
reading shortly or have been rating.
And in Einhard we see an example of an
intellectual of this period and of this
place.
Yeah.
Einhard is active in the court
of Charlemagne. He would be,
Charlemagne is one of Charlemagne. His
biographers, as we know, having read him,
he's also a monastic entrepreneur.
I did say that this society
doesn't incur intellectual,
doesn't encourage intellectual
entrepreneurship in the
sense of coming up with
new ideas.
But it's a very entrepreneurial
society in the sense of getting saints,
getting relics, establishing
monasteries, becoming popular.
It's a very competitive business
environment and Einhard as you've seen,
was very good at this.
He had several monasteries and
churches under his jurisdiction,
but his pet project,
not that far from Frankfurt on
the mine river is elegant stop.
Okay.
And it's an elegant stop that
eventually those relics of Saint Marcel,
Linus and Peter come to rest.
Yeah,
nope. That the saints, Marcel,
Linus and Peter were acquired from Italy,
just like the manuscripts because Italy
is where there are an awful lot of
saints from the Roman martyr period.
There are even more saints actually
in places like North Africa or Egypt,
but they're tough to get at cause
it's a long trip and they're Muslim.
Nevertheless,
we know that lots of relics were liberated
to use a rather 19 seventy's term
from Muslim captivity liberated.
And of course it's not as if Einhard
in talking about what is called the
translation of relics says,
uh,
that he bought them or that, you
know, he came by them quote honestly,
translation meaning here,
the movement,
the moving of the relics
from one place to another.
Marcel,
Linus and Peter were buried in Rome,
uh, and uh, in a church
and Einhard's agents negotiate with this
dubious kind of character who maybe can
get them some relics and maybe not,
and maybe it will require more money or
he's got to talk to a couple of guys.
And uh,
you know,
it's this intrigue and
that's part of the story.
The implication is that Marcel,
Linus and Peter want to move.
They let their tombs be found.
Remember that in looking for st to
it's too heavy to lift the altar up.
They can't do it. On the other
hand, with these saints, no problem.
And once they come to is elegance stop,
they perform all these miracles
which shows they're happy.
They're sure they were stolen.
And in fact,
as Wickham remarks,
and as you've read hell Dwin a competitor
of Einhard's had stolen some of Saint
Marcy Allina's and Einhard
got him to return it,
pressured him to return it,
and eventually healed when was disgraced.
And I can't remember if he's
executed or merely exiled,
but this is a tough business.
So in a 27, these relics, uh, um,
uh, get, uh, moved. Uh, let me
read you since this is in, uh,
in a part of the heart book that,
uh, um, that we didn't assign.
Let me just,
uh,
okay.
Yeah, it begins on page 70, 69 if
you're interested in following this.
And they even have the itinerary of the
relics. So after a fast of three days,
they,
his emissaries traveled by night to
that place without any Roman citizens
noticing them.
Once in the Church of Saint Bertie's,
they first tried to open the altar under
which it was believed his holy body was
located, but the strenuous nature
of the job they had started foiled.
Their plan for the monument
was constructed of extremely
hard marble and easily
resisted the bare hands of those.
Trying to open it. Therefore,
they abandoned the tomb of that martyr
and descended to the tomb of the blessing.
Marsal,
Linus and Peter there.
Once they had called on our Lord Jesus
Christ and adored the holy martyrs,
they were able to lift the
tombstone from its place,
covering the top of the [inaudible].
Then they take it,
they wrap him in a, clean them
in a clean linen shroud. Uh,
um,
oh,
they take just St Marsa [inaudible] and
they wrap him in a shroud and then they
put the tombstone back in place quotes
so that no trace of the body's removal
would remain. But then just as
they're about to make their escape,
the Deacon one of this group
says, oh my God, we can't,
we can't leave without saying, Peter.
These two were companions in life.
We can't just take one
of these bodies were,
if we go back and take the other ones,
they go back and they,
they get the buses and adventure store.
But it's a sacred adventure. Uh, and, uh,
it involves the relics of people who
still have some say in where they want to
be. The very special dead as
Peter Brown refers to them.
And what's very special about them is
that they're not exactly what you would
normally call dead. They're
relics are very much, uh,
active.
Now.
We read in the series of miracles
performed by the saints along with another
sank. They picked up Hermes,
uh, various medical cures.
Notice that these miracles,
unlike Gregory of tour,
are pretty exclusively in one
category. Greg, you have tour,
has a lot of what might be called
scoffers punished miracles.
Somebody either tries to fake a miracle
and then as the victim of a real one or
somebody tries to defy the
bishop or somebody doubts
the efficacy of the saints.
In this case,
most of these miracles,
almost all of them are
people with paralysis.
A disease of the bowels
are horrible sores. Um,
blindness. Um, you know, where to,
how great are these? I know you
could not put this down. Um, and,
and I hope you read it to your
mmm.
Molecular biology roommates,
uh,
just to show how great this is.
Yeah. This, uh,
I think I have this in the
wrong place anyway. Remember
the, uh, the curing of the,
uh, uh, the angry humpback, uh, the,
these guys are carrying the relics two's
elegant star and they stopped to rest
in a field and this angry peasant with
a pitchfork wants to taste them away.
He also has a a humpback and they show
him the relics and say what they're doing
and he falls to his face in adoration.
He is cured of his afflictions and the
people of the village insist that the,
uh, emissaries stay with them,
have a kind of party all night,
bring other villagers in.
Um,
this is an interesting moment and I
mentioned it because here the piety of a
person like Einhard is the same
as the piety of the villagers.
The Carolingian renaissance is mostly
about an elite program to try to preserve
elite forms of knowledge. True. It
is an effort to educate the populace,
but that is probably the
least successful aspect of it.
Hands illiteracy rate in eight 75 was
hardly any greater than it had been in
seven 75.
If you just do a statistical,
if you could do a statistical study,
and it wasn't very high,
but when it comes to the saints and
to the meaning of the supernatural,
okay.
In regular life,
uh,
the most learned,
people have the same attitude
as the villagers, uh,
of this, uh, of this little story.
Okay?
So we've reached the height of the
Carolingian Empire in two days,
and then, uh, our next
discussion will be about,
it's a precipitous and in many respects,
on fortunate decline.
That's what we'll talk about on Wednesday.